نحن مقبلنا على وباء قد يكون اشد فتكا من
كورونا ويحمل اسم المرض اكس هذا ما كشف
عنه وحذر منه خبراء وفي الصحه العامه
فماذا يعني ذلك منظمه الصحه العالميه
اعلنت احتفاظها بقائمه قصيره من الامراض
ذات الاولويه التي قد تسبب وباء قاتلا في
المستقبل ومعظم هذه الامراض باتت معروفه
لدينا كالايبولا والسارس وغيرهما الا ان
هناك تحذيرات جديده من عوامل ممرضه غير
معروفه حاليا قد تتسبب فيما يعرف بالمرض
فمنظمه الصحه عاده ما تستخدم هذا المصطلح
لوصف مرض غير معروف للعلوم الطبيه ويسبب
عدوى للبشريه الخبراء اكدوا ان هذه
الانباء ليست ماده خيال علمي بل هو
سيناريو على العالم الاستعداد له واضافوا
ان المرض اكس سيكون حيوانيا المصدر ما
يعني انه سينشؤ في الحيوانات البريه او
الاليفه ثم ينتشر ليص يب البشر فالموجه
الاخيره من حالات انفلونزا الطيور في
كمبوديا مجرد مثال على ذلك بالطبع وفقا
للخبراء في المقابل يرى خبراء اخرون انه
لا يمكن تجاهل امكانيه وجود ممرض وبائي
معدل هندسيا قد يؤدي الى كارثه المرض اكس
ايضا